[Music]
the prosecution rests that's it
on that he's a plaintiff's lawyer he's
trying to get damages on behalf of his
client the snowboarder
two script errors here major that's like
getting your name wrong
hey legal eagles by popular demand i'm
finally tackling a medical drama that
involves malpractice but
to do that i think i'm going to need a
medical consultation
doctor we're ready for surgery let's dig
in
[Music]
are we losing this case it's too early
to panic okay we haven't presented our
sign
there she is you haven't presented
anything where was his opening statement
where was it where was his opening
statement
where were all the questions that he was
asking of the other witnesses yeah don't
they
like after the witness presents for the
plaintiff right away the defense
gets to speak to them yes well there's
two ways of doing an opening statement
you can
do what's called reserving the opening
statement where instead of giving your
opening statement immediately after the
plaintiff
you wait until the the plaintiff has
presented their whole case and then
at the start of your case then you give
your own opening statement
and there are strategic reasons why you
might do that in a case like this
you would 100 want to go right after get
right in there explain all the things
that the
the plaintiff did not explain to you and
get your theme out there which is that
this is a bad thing that happened to a
good kid it's
not a matter of medical negligence it's
just that all of these complications
that no one could have foreseen
happened caused this whole cascade of
things but the doctors did everything
right
his legs were black i knew it wasn't
good
they cut them off that night so this is
the plaintiff's girlfriend she would
have been a great witness to start
things off
telling the story telling emotional sad
no medical stuff whatsoever and whatever
she witnessed firsthand which is going
to be colored by a lay person it's gonna
it's gonna seem really horrible based on
what she saw that would be a great way
to get your story out there
now did you have any indication that dr
torres was even worried about something
like amputation i mean did she ever
mention that it might be
even a risk no but she was worried about
it
she was worried about what it would do
to her reputation
what are she talking about why would you
say that i have no idea i heard her
talking
in the hallway she didn't know i could
hear her what did she say
she said i can't be the doctor who turns
an olympic athlete into a doorstop
is that hearsay that sounds hearsay that
is uh that is exactly an example of
hearsay however
there is an exception uh to the hearsay
rule in the federal rules it would be
801 d2 federal rules of evidence that is
an admission by a party opponent
so this is the plaintiff using the
statement of the defendant against them
arguably this is a admission by a party
opponent or a declaration against
interest
it's also being used for its non-hearsay
value in terms of
she's literally turning someone into a
doorstep which is incredibly on pc i
can't believe they included that
in here but also that she was flustered
she was worried
she is partially admitting fault so it
sort of informs all of her downstream
actions can you get off of that thing
for five seconds and look at this place
yeah no hold on a sec i'm just uh i'm
following up on that clinical trial in
germany using peterson hip joints i'm
trying to get them to send me their data
well they're not gonna release anything
until it's published
sometimes they will it's called the
pre-print publication is that the kind
of research that an orthopedic surgeon
would do before
doing surgery for the first time using a
hip that she's never used before
uh it should be because you want to know
what the implications of using the joint
would be
what side effects patients had
especially if it's different than the
research that already exists i would
expect that a surgeon at the top of her
field
would research clinical trials she would
examine whatever
publications the manufacturer has put
out it's not like there's hundreds of
studies that they have to go through
there's like a handful that are good
quality
so like two three studies that you go
through and you know them inside out you
know what the complications are
and you present it to the patient
getting them to understand what the
risks would be
and again that's not the core of the
problem here the core of the problem is
how she acted after the procedure so
like
that's the real issue here i don't think
the joint is even the problem
oh that's it that's how she does her
research like oh okay now show me this
i sent a text yeah trying to explain
that to the jury you have to believe me
i did everything i could
look at this text i dm'd the author
that actually would have come out in
evidence really oh yeah there would be
so much discovery and document requests
and you would absolutely look for
electronic documents including emails
texts anything that references the hip
travis reed the snowboarder
you'd ask for all of that from the
doctor and it would have been turned
over to the other side
so for example the plaintiff can request
personal emails as well
oh absolutely that's really the bread
and butter of litigation these days
people are relatively smart in terms of
not saying things that they shouldn't
say or at least not having a record of
it
people say all kinds of crazy stuff
anything else
hey travis hey you know i'm uh
i'm thinking about snowboarding in fact
i've picked up a board uh burton blunt
you familiar with that one
good board no you can't ask these
questions
there's better boards for beginners what
size you are i must
13. you might want to look into an extra
wide objective
don't hang over too much now a little
overhang's fine but too much is going to
cause drag yeah it drags bad
well objection your honor where is this
going objection
where is this going that is not an
objection recognized by the federal
rules of evidence
you'd be objecting from the very start
of this this is not relevant
i get it you're trying to humanize your
client
but you the way you would do that is
establishing the background
that is actually relevant to his
economic and non-economic damage 100
he's not able to snowboard now so the
obvious form of damages would be the
lost income that he would have been able
to make
and that would be a huge part of this
case too in terms of disputing
whether he would even be able to
snowboard in the future because remember
he started out this
episode with arthritis so arthritis so
severe
that he couldn't land the trick he
couldn't land the trick and he needed a
replacement hip
that's one of the reasons why you might
bifurcate a trial like this which means
that
half of the trial is about establishing
liability who was negligent
which parties were negligent doctor
hospital etc and then
only once you've established the
relative fault so
you can have this person is responsible
for 10 this person is responsible for 50
percent
once you've established that then you
would go forward into damages and then
there would be a huge battle
where the defense would say maybe we
were negligent
but this poor kid was never going to be
able to snowboard again
anyway therefore we don't owe damages in
the form of his lost income
is it true that dr torres had never
actually done an operation with this
kind of droid before
objection speculation he knows that
because she told him
that's an example where probably the
hearsay wouldn't come in okay
it's sort of speculation as to whether
that is in fact your case okay
it's true but you went ahead with it
anyway she said she had done a lot of
research
she said she was confident so you
trusted her to use her expertise to
advise you
and to keep you safe when in fact what
you got
was a bot surgery an infection this is a
leading question
an extremely leading question
that's not a question you don't get to
pontificate
from the well of the court the main
thing is you have to ask
actual questions in an examination these
aren't actual questions
there's nothing there
i'm really interested to see how she
handles this because i think
situations like this decide whether or
not a patient is actually going to
continue
if you come in and you take some of the
fault yourself and you actually say
sorry statistics show less likely for a
lawsuit to happen
interesting but doctors i don't know if
this is like older training
and ego thing what is it but they're
afraid to say sorry and say we made a
mistake
and as a result more like it looks worse
to the patient
the doctor doesn't care they're not
going to fix this other patients are
going to get hurt by this
whereas if you apologize point out what
you did wrong point out what you learned
how you're changing the system
so it never happens again less it
doesn't protect you obviously but
it gives that honesty to the patient
where they're less likely to proceed
with litigation well i would assume that
doctors are
worried about getting sued and admitting
fault so that is a reason why they would
but isn't it interesting that it's
actually backwards
something similar happens when you're
questioning patients something that med
students are always hesitant to ask is
if patients are thinking about
committing suicide or hurting themselves
and students i don't want to ask that
what if it actually leads them to do
that
no such evidence asking that question
does not offend people
it does not cause more rates of suicide
and it's actually reassuring and you
can get a lot of information that could
actually help you protect the patient
from committing suicide yeah i imagine
that's one of the reasons why
empirical evidence-based medicine is so
important exactly because everyone has
these hunches but yeah
sometimes it's not borne out in the data
exactly it's dr torres
fault improper opinion objection move to
strike
you feel very strongly about that it's
not just a feeling
i know it she told me but she admitted
that she was at fault
yeah she did i'm curious about this the
day she cut off my legs she came into my
room she'd been crying
she told me she was sorry objection it
is illegal to use a physician's apology
against him as evidence of guilt your
honor
this isn't about the apology this is
about everything else she said
with the apology i'll allow it
oh okay so big problems here okay
i hope so it is in fact the case that
there are about 40 states in the u.s
that have what are called i'm sorry laws
which as you just talked about
allow the facilitation of doctors to
apologize
to a patient in those states it is
illegal to use the doctor's apology
against them in court like this there
are limits to that though if the doctor
goes
further than apologizing into admitting
fault then that is a statement that's
not covered by the i'm sorry laws and
can be admissible
she said if there was anyone to blame it
was her
she said this never should have happened
she said if there was any way she could
change things she would
those were her exact words yeah i don't
think that's really admitting faults
yes they were
[Music]
the prosecution rests that's it on that
no that's not the issue he's a
plaintiff's lawyer the prosecution is a
criminal thing
he's saying that he represents the state
and is prosecuting someone
for criminal guilt he's a plaintiff's
lawyer he's trying to get damages on
behalf of his client the snowboarder
two script errors here major that wow
and then them
saying post-operative infections are
common in the middle of surgery when he
didn't even have his infection yet
that's like getting your name wrong and
the surgery
it went smoothly the cut position
and the femoral resurfacing were perfect
what wasn't perfect
well at the end of surgery the patient
decided which
means his oxygen level went down and his
heart was beating really fast which is
really dangerous we thought he might
have a clot in his lungs
so it was vital that we finished the
surgery quickly and that's when you left
the sponge
yes and i would do it again so this is
actually really good direct examination
yeah i agree
and the defense is actually putting
their main witness
first which is probably the right way to
go it's either that or go with an expert
um
it's sort of crazy that the plaintiff
did not have an expert
um you would have multiple experts in a
suit like this
it would be a battle of the experts well
the patient's life was at risk
i believed that the sponge wouldn't
compromise the joint i made a call
and i was right it was the right call so
leaving the sponge was deliberate
not a mistake you weren't being careless
or distracted
i mean i think at this point we haven't
seen anything that's related to the
sponge at all we actually never heard
about the sponge again
what does a sponge have to do with him
getting an infection
in his heart leading to septic emboli
going to his legs and losing his legs
unless the sponge caused an infection
in the hip and then because of that
sponge being there
then his hip was infected then his heart
was infected and then
uh he threw the cloth we have to assume
that they left the sponge in for weeks
because he went
home came back with a fever yeah so he
still hasn't
if they thought there was a sponge but
they needed to close to make sure he
wasn't having a pulmonary embolism
they closed they check he's not having a
pulmonary embolism
then they do the x-ray to see if there's
a sponge in fact in there why would they
send them home with a sponge well they
might have been incredibly negligent
well then that's like
that's not her fault then it's a
hospital issue make sure his bp and our
tucson stay stable
and bring me his post-op x-ray i want to
locate that sponge see yeah
i'm on team sponge it's my job to
prioritize my patient and that's exactly
what i did
i wasn't focused on anything or anyone
other than my patient
let's talk about this embolectomy what
happened to the post-op
sponge i guess we'll never know you know
what's funny in the beginning of the
opening statement he said there's one
crucial mistake right and i can't wrap
my head around what the
there's so many mistakes i don't know
which one is the one they're going after
it's a cornucopia of medical mistakes
exactly let's talk about this
embolectomy
dr yang wanted to do the heart surgery
first you
want to work on travis's leg yes why
well his foot was turning gray oh okay
so
this doctor is saying that she wasn't
distracted and we know that there were
things going on that obviously affected
her judgment this would have come out in
the deposition presumably the other
attorney would have asked
what was going on that day were you
distracted in any way
and they might know the information that
she's withholding from the jury
here and if you do that it's the
absolute worst thing you can do because
true it might be an ancillary thing but
to the jury it look awful
you have lied in front of the jury and
now your credibility is toast and you
are going to be found liable
well his foot was turning gray which is
an indication
that the limb is starting to die and i
wanted to restore blood flow
once a limb turns black there's nothing
we can do as a vascular
surgeon you are an orthopedic surgeon
could she have dual specialties
ah no they're not even related maybe
like a vascular cardiothoracic
you see how you could be like a vascular
surgeon that works on the lower body
as well as someone who works in the
chest but a dual board certification and
orthopedic and vascular
i've never heard of that she knew that
the heart would keep throwing out clots
until it was repaired
a little okay let's say you're cooking
and you start a grease fire in your
kitchen
and then it spreads too is she
questioning her own counsel i mean
it's rhetorical okay you can get away
with it okay what do you do do you
put out the grease fire or do you
extinguish the curtains which disaster
do you tackle first it's so cynical of
these writers
oh she's she's talking in terms that the
jury can understand
i don't understand it i can't follow the
analogy though they needed to
tackle the worst thing first yeah so
it's but was that the worst thing
it probably does the fact that the heart
is throwing out clots all over the place
and they'll continue throwing out clouds
whether or not you fix the light it's
not a perfect metaphor yeah
if i can't feel for my patients without
getting sued and i guess i'm just gonna
keep on getting sued because that's who
i
am uh i mean i
don't think i would want my client to
say that she's gonna be
sued multiple times this is one of those
times where maybe she's lapsing into a
narrative which technically you're not
supposed to do but
if i was the plaintiff's lawyer i don't
want to come off as overbearing and
argumentative and objecting even if i'm
right on a ticky-tack objection
you just let it go you let her tell her
story and and
let things move along i think
it's from a clinical trial on the
peterson head i thought i never heard
back
i thought i never heard that well he
probably should have followed up on that
and close as the daddy requested but
please be advised we've currently put a
stop to our trial
there have been five instances of
infection caused by the pseudomonas
bacteria
why we trace the source back to the
peterson joint
wait so it wasn't the sponge no
apparently it was the
the hip manufacturer so why do they keep
talking about the sponge if it was never
in the patient i don't think he's a good
lawyer
that's such a problem so they closed
worried that there was a sponge
there was in fact no sponge and yet
they're still discussing it in the sport
it's a big swing and a miss
i can't just sit on this i have to tell
them right i wouldn't you didn't
willfully ignore any doubt yeah you
didn't act irresponsibly
or maliciously you worked off the
information you had at the time
well okay act of god i like that word so
okay so
that is technically true she acted on
the information she had at the time
so in that sense she wasn't actively
reckless she didn't know that it was
i guess a recalled hip the thing is if
you get the hip in order to get it you
would have known about the recoil
right exactly yeah yeah it's not like
you get it off ebay like
if this clinical trial is having
multiple instances of this infection
yeah it's a defective hip
i'm sure peterson has recalled this hip
if she didn't check to see if that no
you can't get it you physically can't
get there
like it's not like they send it to you
and they're like well you should check
if it's recalled no you're ordering it
from the caveat mtor
buyer beware the only thing is that they
could have pre-ordered the hip
got it before the recall then the recall
happened possibly there's a lot of
negligence going on here
hey okay
thanks they've reached a verdict
that's quick well we have no idea where
we are in time right now
so it's not uncommon to engage in
settlement discussions
with the other side right up until the
time the jury actually announces
real oh yeah absolutely wow because at
that point people get nervous
people get nervous all the evidence is
out you know how the trial went yeah
so you hear about people settling on the
courtroom steps
happens all the time wow happens all the
time i've literally written out
a settlement in bullet points on a legal
pad transcribing
inside the hallway sign both sides it's
kind of kind of like a letter of intent
wow so then at that point do you
stop the jury negotiation yep you just
go in front of the judge and say your
honor we don't need to hear the verdict
we have decided to set up wow that's so
cool
i think it's gonna be like if she
presents that letter and it's entered
into evidence
it's either gonna be clearly her fault
because the manufacturer did reach out
many times and she just missed it not
just a solo letter or it's completely
the manufacturer's fault
because sending one letter like that is
not sufficient to say hey this hip is
completely malfunctioning i would really
like to see the text messages
some person at the peterson institute
hey hey dr torres
gonna insert this real quick hip
recalled lol
can an apology actually heal our wounds
no well not literally
someone to save her from my self
ease our pain always
[Music]
wait what you don't know no no
maybe it's too late
how do you know what he said he i'm
pretty sure what he mouthed was
not guilty that's a prosecution that's
that's a criminal thing
yeah it was never an option that she was
ever going to jail but good job you're
not guilty
all i'm saying is hashtag missing sponge
because if there was no sponge
and it was caused by an infection of the
actual joint
she literally did nothing wrong maybe
the sponge traveled down his leg
[Laughter]
it wasn't an embolectomy that was needed
to solve who's a sponge activist
[Music]
mike on my channel i give these videos a
grade for
legal realism will you join me in giving
it a grade for medical realism do they
want me to
no will i yes we're doing it anyway i
think that's the longest review i've
ever done of an episode certainly
metaphorically if not literally
based on how much time it took well
because without a sponge if
if the sponge don't fit you gotta quit
i'd have to say
that based on everything that we saw
grey's anatomy gets a
d-minus at best how
generous it's an f minus for me on this
episode i could not follow it medically
f f minus lots of negligence which i'd
love to see but
other than that totally unwatchable this
is a super long episode so be sure to
check out part one on dr mike's channel
well dr mike i'm sorry to say that our
patient
barely survived the operation uh but if
you'd like to see
more reactions to even more ridiculous
legal dramas
check out this playlist with all of my
other legal reactions and dr mike's
channel for
the best reactions to all of the crazy
medical dramas out there
i'll see you in court